I'm still stuck perhaps because I'm
hungry in the uh in the rating of human
preferences for candy so I have to ask
what's the best candy I like this ELO
rating for candy somebody should come
off because you're somebody who says you
like chocolate what's what do you think
is the best I'll probably put Milk Duds
up there I don't know if you know do you
have a preference for chocolate or candy
oh I have lots of preferences I've I've
uh I'm one of my all-time favorites is
my whole life is these things these
flake things Cadbury flakes which are
not much sold in the US and I've always
thought that was a sign of a of a a lack
of respect for the American Consumer
because they're these sort of aerated
chocolate that's made in a in a whole
sort of uh it's kind of a sheet of
chocolate that's kind of folded up and
when you eat it flakes fall all over the
place ah so it requires a kind of
Elegance it requires you to have an
Elegance well I know what I usually do
is you know a piece of paper or
something Embrace nothing else and clean
it up after no I actually eat the I eat
the flakes I said that because you know
it turns out the way food tastes depends
a lot on its physical structure and you
know it really you know I've noticed
when I eat pieces of chocolate I usually
have some little piece of chocolate and
I I always break off little pieces
partly because then I eat it less fast
yeah but also because it actually tastes
different
um you know the the small pieces you
know have a different you have a
different experience than if you have
the big slab of chocolate for many
reasons yes slower
more intimate
because it's I think it's also just pure
physicality or the texture of a change
yes right it's fascinating now I take
back my mailbox because that's such a
basic answer